right now the schools are trying to
force the fouchy algae on a bunch of
healthy kids
who face
statistically very very very very low
risk of hospitalization or death from
coronavirus an infinitesimally small
risk
and at least according to one study from
uc davis
they might face some risk from
the vaccine and we don't we really don't
know there are no long-term data on the
vaccine just by definition the vaccine
is very new
and so
there's a real question parents are
facing why would i inject my kid with
this experimental drug
when the drug is supposed to protect
against a virus that poses
almost no very very low risk to him
well that argument is getting buttressed
by a very serious well-credentialed
epidemiologist that would be
professor harvey rich at yale so one of
the top schools in the country
harvey rich says if you as a parent are
facing the choice between
injecting your kid with the fouchy algae
even if he is otherwise healthy and
pulling your kid out of school
you should probably do the latter
if the child has chronic conditions that
make their risk appreciable
then there's a reason that they would
should be considered for vaccination
other than that
if it were my child i would homeschool
them honestly i would organize with
other parents
to take them out of the school and
create homeschooling environments there
there's no choice your child's life is
on the line it's not a high risk
vaccination is not a high risk that's
going to kill every child by doing so
however it's enough of a risk that on
the average the benefit is higher for
homeschooling than it is for for
vaccination and being in school and
that's just the bottom line you know we
were seeing employees in companies
facing mandates quit or being fired and
now the public perceives that and
and companies are having a hard time
replacing those employees in the climate
of of a bad employment circumstances and
and missing workers it's getting even
harder so those policies are being
rethought when the people rebel because
of their own interests then it has to be
reckoned it does have to be reckoned and
i think the great relief here for a lot
of people is not even that
that this guy is pointing out the the
questions about the vaccine or you know
permitting the
at least giving parents the
permission the intellectual permission
to go put their kids in homeschool
it's that finally we're seeing a
scientist who sees the big picture
this was this was one thing that really
bugged me
about trump i know his back was against
a wall he was facing this unprecedented
crisis and everyone and every
power in the entire country was coming
after him and demanding that he lock
down and listen to fouchy but the big
mistake here
for those early coronavirus press
conferences
was that the only people who talked were
trump
and the doctors
right fouchy and dr scarf and the other
one that surgeon general jerk who
spends all his time now just attacking
conservatives
was this jerome powell is that his name
jerome not jerome powell
jerome adams yes that's right jerome
adams so
why is that the problem well the left
said all we should be listening to
is dr fauci and dr scarf and jerome
adams
we
all we should be listening to are the
doctors but that's not true because it
it's a country we're talking about the
politics politics refers to public
things there's more to the public than
just germs
trump also probably should have had a
military advisor get up there and speak
and had an economic advisor get up there
and speak and had a constitutional
advisor get up there and speak and had
people speak from different segments of
society because what what the president
is supposed to do in particular but what
our public representatives are supposed
to do is bring together all these
different segments all these different
interests in society so that we can have
a coherent balanced public policy but
that's not how the regime wants to
govern itself okay that is not how the
technocratic progressive regime wants to
be wants to be just run by a bunch of
eggheads that kick out every other
interest in society hey you thanks for
watching that clip i'm glad you liked it
i enjoyed producing that clip for you
sometimes people are not told when i i
put clips out there i don't know maybe
our friends here at youtube maybe they
don't always want to tell people one way
you can ensure that that you will get
notifications ring that bell subscribe
the best way to ensure you get
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
type in the michael knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review i'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]